I move it a little bit, do it a little bit, no stop, no we've just got nausea, we're
doing good.
Just nausea, literally shaking right now mommy please hold the line, it's when he was here
no she has abandoned, reflin, reflin food, my burp, my chunder, oh now he's a perplexed
man I'm getting, I'm getting shaky I'm getting nervous, what, I don't understand that last
remark, I don't get it, I've never felt such sadness, no you're fine, it's fine, good morning
good evening, good afternoon, can you hear me? Hi mommy, hi reflin, you're okay, everything's
fine, okay.
Turns out Peggle is a stupidly old game that I had no concept of, the dang thing was they
tried to load the neverhin, put it this way, the game that you see on stream is bigger
than what I can actually see, it's locked into this tiny little fucking box that I can't
see anything with, so I'm gonna be playing through OBS pretty much is what's gonna happen
and this game is so old, it didn't even let you touch the main menu options, it just threw
me into tutorial mode and I'm like no, I haven't even started streaming yet, it literally
threw me in, the lego lord of the rings vods got fucking annihilated by copyright, like
if nothing happens I'm happy to put them up later, when I say annihilated you say huh,
like no it's fine, my 17 hours of streams, I didn't want them up anyway, absolutely everything
has been, any song from the franchise has been decimated, like the two of them had been
completely blocked from a ton of countries and I'm like oh my god is this gonna affect
my channel, so what I've done, I've privated them, if nothing seems to happen I will put
them back up at a later date but right now I'm a bit cautious cause like that's the worst
I've ever seen anything on my channel so far, no don't vomit, those are good streams, yeah
like I think I ended streaming and it looked fine, it all looked fine and then I think
I refreshed the page or whatever cause I was just checking the comments cause we were
improving the burp comments cause they're the big nasty burp in the middle of one of
the streams and all I get is notification notification notification, I'm like oh my god what's
going on and then like that's when it all registered that like everything had been annihilated
to Kingdom coming back so yeah thanks YouTube, didn't want my 17 hours of stream up anyway,
no, five minutes ago I thought staying up to 8am was a bad idea, irresponsible, take
a minute for the audio jungle cause I'm worried about being nuked up where I need to get coffee
right bro, hopefully, but yes today's stream is peggle, please don't forget to leave a
like for the pegging community is dying, this game is old, I didn't realise how old
it was, I don't remember, I just remember playing the trial on xbox and cause I didn't
I used to play the trials cause I didn't have any money and I had to ask my dad for the
game so I got to play trials of things all the time and as I said if nothing happens
with the Lord of the Rings boards like nothing seems to be imperative then I'm happy to just
fart them back up again but I'm a bit nervous at this point in time cause the sea of red
on it is crazy, yeah but all enter will fill screen the game for you, ah I mean as long
as you can see that's the main thing, it doesn't really matter if I can see bro, I just need
my light to rubber up at them, but yes we're gonna play peggle, we're just gonna muck
around, I don't know how loud the game's gonna be so do forgive me, if it's not that good
and then afterwards I'm gonna need about 5 minutes to set up my hand cam membership
ASMR, um yeah and he said the webcam up for that and my desk is a mess as always, actually
you know what, no no no all F4s, oh yeah sure, I believe ya, I believe ya, um yeah I've got
um, I know I said the next membership ASMR was gonna be 1000 kisses before I can talk
but I can't do it for the current one that I'm planning because I need to show you the
item and we're gonna test it and if you guys think it's good then we'll do a public stream
with it and if it's rubbish then it'll be forever or, honestly I'm gonna get peh, hi
momay, hi son, hi replay, good morning, good evening, good afternoon, sorry if I sound
tired, yeah it turns out tryharding on lego lord of the rings for 13 hours in one day,
I don't know, it's a little bit, I hate to say, I hate to be that streamer that's like
you know what that took it out of me, but again be some credit, that was a 13 hour stream
it took it out of me, I couldn't sleep and I've been having a dull tummy ache and I'm
like how did I get rid of this and before anyone goes ketchup season, I'm sure you
have had many a ketchup in many a season, I know the difference between the pain of
ketchup season and a dull tummy ache, 13 hours, so we broke the board and then I had to make
another like 30 minute private thing, so I technically did go over the 12 hour mark
into the 13 if you can read the name, hello hi replay, I've never played half life, no
everyone was mental for it though so maybe I should, for those of you who weren't able
to see the vlog, again it was copyright issues, but I finished it and I got a sugar ton of
gifted memberships so you can already see there's a new emoteslot unlocked before I've
even ordered the next batch, technically people get it, sometimes sitting for a long time
does give a bit of a tiny time to be seen, yeah I'm not really sure, ketchup season took
me a second, well I see this was one of the things you guys taught me, I didn't know if
a VTuber says they have a slow tummy, sometimes that's codeword for ketchup season and I
said it many months ago, I was like oh my stomach kinda hurts and like folk were like
oh my god it's her ketchup season, I'm like no I've never talked about that, no relax,
and then I got taught about that and I was like oh that's not any of that mean, a little
ketchup fact, no she's pregnant, no that's October, such a broad term it could mean anything,
but literally what we're saying, don't worry guys she says this is when she is ketchup season
and no need to hit, shark wait, now I'm a cuttlefish, I don't like sharks, they eat me,
nine minutes it's over, the tea got her, my tea is actually warm, I strategically made the tea
later than I usually do, so you're just, I'm sorry you're just forced to talk to me, oh I can't
believe it, I'm gonna open up Marshmallow, they're just forced to talk to me, regarding the void,
Archive Brewers managed to grab the first, you need me to unprivate the last one,
mommy wait wait eight minutes ago, mommy where are you, I'm gonna throw up, I must have literally
been clicking go live as you typed that, you good boy, I'm Ethan, I can do 120 push-ups,
yeah you know what I can do, sleep like a cat for eight hours, bagel hardly even know her, okay,
apologies if I sent this so I saw you fine, um table top stimulator, yes I'm afraid I don't know
how to use it though, but I think I have it, but it's a good six man game, yeah, um,
Johnny I just want to say as a fan I think you did a good job, oh well I'm not allowed to upgrade
you to refund status, no, I've got mild tummy, it could be a baguette, ketchup wheat, a bastard,
oh no I managed to bake a loaf of bread, I repeat a loaf of bread has been baked so I feel fine in
that department again, um, some banjo feedback, no considering I've not even streamed on it yet,
you're a bit too early on the feedback for me Reefland, what the fuck I ain't even streamed yet,
that's funny, sorry I couldn't say it for the last time, don't worry about it Reefland, those
streams are ridiculous, love you, I love you too Reefland, please don't worry, again my voice is
probably just I'm very tired, I promise I'm here and I'm happy and I'm bintzining, hot pen streamers
who shitted, what is the agendation for tomorrow, I know I have a collab coming up, I need to make sure,
oh it's tomorrow, bleat I need to learn how to play dead by daylight, bleat it's tomorrow,
can't let the girls down, okay, how can we know when you'll stream on the other site, um, I,
you are better putting your stonks into the other girls right now, I am fucking swapping so many
hats right now, like right now my job is to catch up on my own work and open up the established
clipper program for vealer, um, I'm afraid I don't even have the ability to feel anything when I,
when the bean has stopped, there's no other way to say it, I have like no, I have negative
riz against it right now, um, it's just awful, it's like the gate, it's like the great stories
Mr Frodo, the ones that really mattered, full of darkness and danger they were, and sometimes you
didn't want to know the end because how could the end be happy, how could the world go back
to the way it was when so much bad has happened, but in the end it was only a passing thing this
shadow, even darkness must pass, a new day will come and when the sun shines it'll shine out the
clear, I know now folks in these stories had lots of chances of turning back, only they didn't,
we kept going because we were holding on to something that there's some good in this world,
Mr Frodo, and it's worth fighting, so thank you, I like that one very much, the vault, the timer on
the vault door is ticking with the fuck we're playing Fallout 1 need to get that fucking water
chip or something, please tell me this is from memory, you hilarious, no I was reading, no chance,
right will we pegglers, oh wait no I've not had my tea yet that's why I'm talking,
sorry this is why I do a pre-yap, it's to drink the tea while it's warm, okay let's test it out,
oh I got a review on my Patreon audio, are you ready?
fucking hell cuttles, that grooving audio is too good, you really let loose through the sass,
the sarcasm and the anger, then with a mix of sections where you're enjoying yourself just,
I was desperately holding back the urge to grab my torch and jackhammer that whole,
like how I think about jackhammering yours, why didn't you? I hear you say, it's because it's late
and the neighbours are all up and they'd hear me pounding it as a grunt moaning panter name
while recording an audio for you, pregnant via your rear, you didn't even know how much of an ink dump
I'd turn you into by trying, I gave me something wet mess on holy juices dripping on every muscle
twitch, wet every muscle twitch and aftermath that would be make a demon to blush as they walked in,
damn women why do you drive me so fucking barrel at times, why the accent, oh this
because the AI can't pick up my heavy Scottish accent so I can see what I want when I'm a heavy
Scottish and when I'm really heavy Scottish you should check out the closed captions, it doesn't
have a fucking clue what I'm on about half the time, but until the Scottish patch comes to AI
I'm gonna abuse the fuck out of that, thank you for the audio reviews if you guys ever send me
them, I fucking love them especially like when it comes to the me or Mimsa, that is the most
change in my life Scottish buffy, five head play, are you'll be pegging, yeah we're gonna peg in
two minutes once I finish my tea, can you unlock comments on Patreon, because I do not have the
time, resources nor want to spend money on a team that would remove negative comments for myself
or any of the girls so the only way to give feedback is via Marshmallows, on the topic of
Patreon feedback you're always welcome to message me if there's some things going on with your girl
because I tell the script master, like myself and the script master in communication the girls
just fill the scripts okay so don't if you're like really not vibing what the pic was this month
you're more than happy to give feedback we try to do what we do is a we cast the net okay
now it's impossible that everything produced by one single content creator you're gonna love
you're gonna adore it's gonna be perfect you're gonna eat it up that's not possible so let's
you know just start with that in the conversation and two again the girls do the scripts they are
provided them unless the girls um I did see some of them potentially right in their some scripts even
if it was a one-off here and there with their respective um mascot name um so you might have
more personal things like that but as as a overall thing um is Halo CE live going to be story mode
or the multiplayer um the story mode the one where the and he like crash lands and he's the only
survivor because he's like me it was so good it made me and the beginning was really happening for
a second let me and you're gonna grab my oh wait hold on i need a muffle myself
okay it's time it's time to peg i'm halfway done my tea
literally i stole that joke there's like some massive twitter thing
and it was like the peggle community is dying retweet if you like pegging and i'm like you yank
my stream title no
mommy has the ability to call herself she would have one for streaming than rest people
with every last few things i'm not being funny i always say this if i had a twin we would be
on the same wavelength about everything so fucking you'd stream with one of us one day
and then the night and the other one would be offline like ed and asmr and shiz nice and easy
and retweet how big is your cup oh it's just a regular size cup not the skinny ones for like
older people you know how like the elderly kind of have like a weak appetite uh no mine's like a
it's not a sports direct mug type of tea
the strongy one and strongy two
we'd be like right i i don't know how loud this is gonna be
oh you mean we could have had background ambience this entire time oh my god listen to that smooth
jazz i'm gonna turn it down to weave it this game is rather loud
hit him
okay so as i said it just threw me into the tutorial
oh i'll plug my controller in by guess if it's no go sleep uh i guess i fucking just use key
um a little cursor oh my god you can see my cursor do you like it
i just did the worst shot ever i'm so sorry i don't know what i'm doing i'm so sorry
i am so sorry i thought that was gonna go straight down oh my god that was awful
right so what i'm no this is even what that cursor can get it is it turning on
look at that little nozzle
are we winning i don't know how to win this game i want the red
okay
uh tell me that's not rigged why did they even do that pathway please tell me i'm not bad at
this game too i'm like so bad at all the games i want to try i just start playing this shelf
lane what the fuck you have the purple the red ones to win oh oh my god wait how
okay sorry that's ai cheating because what the fuck i did not hit that okay do the red ones got it
come on that's ai cheating there's no way that's naturally happen i don't believe it for a second
oh
favor score nice what that was good i like that okay i understand that this level has
bricks clear the orange bricks and orange pegs to pass the level shout out to the pegging community
that flow straight into 100k easy peasy right i'm gonna just start beating the side
and it gets stuck oh i guess removed okay
i guess if the thing goes in the hole i get another one
this game gives crazy serotonin oh no are we gambling
do i need to turn down the thing the music or anything stop acting we're no you're i'm actually mlg
pro i'm rank 61 in this game you'll never believe it i've got five left oh i don't think we're
gonna do it no way no i don't know how to like trick shot it i'm just letting the game do it honestly
yeah like the i got a free ball i got a free ball
it's in maui in maui
okay there we go mlg pegging down the street um we love the pego community
wow fever score high score
total score half a million went on first try so i can lose green pegs activate magic powers
the first magic power is super gate it lasts for the next three turns what the heck is super gate
double guide no i don't know if i wanted that i'm gonna be honest i don't know if i wanted to
double up on it in the better time that thing the game isn't cheating for it it's just pego
it's for the what is super guide it's is that it it shows you where that stuff's gonna go
i have to admit i do like the ai taking over like yes please i suck thank you
i guess that's why the game's like so highly rated and satisfying because it does all the thinking for you
uh it shows you where the next bounce will go that's right i like i mean i think i could guess
in general where we might have gone oh we got a free shot from that right we've got seven left
okay let's do this one
okay we're getting a bit rough not gonna lie getting a bit rough
how am i oh right how am i supposed to get that one when all of these are in my way
i don't know maybe just okay there we go we got like rid of all of them in the way
okay i get it now i'm i understand i understand why this game is so highly rated
i understand i get it now oh my god i get it now
we gave in the purple pick is worth big points score over 25 000 points on a shot to get a free
ball
did i do it i don't know
free ball right oh i got double free ball right let's get that one
i love the way it just like pops off the map it's like okay i'm done
you miss this game straight into 100k again easy peasy streamer luck if that if that's not like
common right let's do that okay close enough i'll take it
oh no oh it keeps changing as well the the bonus ball like the purple one
we save and peggle with this one so it's technically a pinball derived game i think so
there's like a peggle too i like thought this was on xbox game pass peggle one and it was me
um
it was me at all to buy this on steam and then think i don't know if peggle two is good or not
but i mean honestly this is rather satisfying don't have to think you know oh my god controversial
take i don't know if i'm allowed to say this out loud i think it reminds me of like the suica
game where you can kind of just tune out not really care about the gameplay that much it's that bad
of me i don't know it feels like i have one fucking ball left yeah peace off mate okay let's try again
clear blue pegs out of the way um excuse me what the actual fuck are you really mad you'll learn
peggle two is the same but with tower ups extra aside oh yeah and we'll come on ei let me win
no it just like falls off the map it does absolutely nothing like oh thanks mate i guess
you lost or anytime to go ball we gotta go ball what the hell i got superguide
game this is good this is nice i like it anyway but i think this is like a very
dare i say casual game but in a good way like this is chill i'm gonna be honest after i
13 i was stream yesterday pretty much uh i'll i'll take this boom oh you didn't see that you
didn't see that it's okay you didn't see that you didn't see it that's so embarrassing oh well
i'm getting nervous oh i got free ball right fuck you bitch in my way
um
peggle can get serious fast oh no i'm not i'm not gonna be a filthy casual
my toll score is a million when on the second try you got fisticating right let's try that game
the ball will head where you click okay you can fine-tune your shot with a mouse wheel and arrow
isn't haven't we already like established that or
competitive pegger stop actually i'm though i'm like mlg at this game you guys have no idea
i'm gonna be so good by the end of this stream we're gonna be doing trick shots we'll be
nasty moves and stuff oh yeah oh yeah long shot extra bonus seats are all coming together
i only have six shots left what the heck oh complain and you shall receive amen
oh right how am i supposed to get these
i don't think i do oh well that backfire to
ai coming in clutch
oh my god i love the ai in this game what the fuck i so kind thank you developer teams you
know what you know what satisfaction is okay oh my god this is so good
favor score 25 as if i made 69 fever point did they know just the game no
what's this multiple madness master jimmy leighton all right a fresh student are you ready for
multiple it's pretty extreme but you look like you can handle it use it early for mad points for
hit both green pegs in one shot for some massive multiple come on let's do it wait what there's
like a proper campaign my multiple pop an extra out when you hit a green peg
oh my god wait this game has like different
oh my gosh oh i missed sorry oh well i hit something on the way down
that's insane oh what the heck there's like a character literally a character select and like
pegle of all game
okay i'm trying to get like
no stop doing that the game hates me i need the ai to take over the pegle more like pachinko it
does remind me a little bit pachinko i don't know if you guys have ever watched this um like how
it's called well how about casino worker oh that was a really bad move it's like how a casino worker
like works in japan um and like he works in this pachinko thing which is um a really loud
like play area like it's so freaking loud but everyone's like addicted to it okay i don't know
right ai please ai please take over okay thank you okay
oh i missed oh that would have been so cool okay let's try that again
i like that it is inspired by pachinko oh is it
um only in this game is the mythical physics engine well i love the physics engine because
i'm actually i have a chance to win you see if it takes over have a chance to win but if it
doesn't take over it's over let's go gambling in japan oh we've got one orange too we only got
two orange that really wasn't worth it that much
there's like so many blue in the okay that's what's like killing the run
it's what's killing the run because of all these blues in the way
i can't believe it
is this chat also crazy about magic what does that mean
if you get the it will you'll experience true ai do we have enough time to get there
i'm actually losing though uh and before it takes me like five hours to do this one level
um i'm just gonna go for the the old uh there's no way in heck where we're gonna get all that
somehow right drop it with your ai advice go one orange two orange three four
okay
they're clearing it out over there get to work get to work okay
no stop bouncing the only thing that should be bouncing is you on my peggle gameplay
okay i think that bouncing jump you can get there but you can also get stuck wait the game
can actually get hard doesn't the game take pity on me ai you can tell this is my third round
get in there lucky bounce damn right lucky bounce
i'm sure there's probably a better tactic to the way i'm doing it but
come on ai you know what you want to do give it to me baby
get clear these ones yeah that's what we want i've got a random free ball i'll take it
can we do it i don't know like this
i'm gonna mess up
the ai is you rimshot rimshot is that what we're calling it
the difficulty goes up i can't believe it oh my god i go hit the green peg on the left
side to make the multi ball pop on the right side
what i don't know i'm gonna i'm gonna just send it i'm gonna just let them have fun
uh sure you
i love all the random hit has anyone raged at peggle i wouldn't say i've raged this game
you want me to i can make it happen
imagine not having the curse to tell you where the ball would go
well is there like a mod or something our setting is like aim assist
oh that wasn't a good one i'm a bit weak
there's really so much i can do i need to aim for the red one so
what do you want from me oh that was really lucky the other one oh that's not good
well that worked out a heck of a lot better than it that could have been so much way
okay you and then i do have enough if i don't mess up the shots basically i could just hit one at a
time went till you lock the magic bunny wait how did everyone know the lore of this game but me
okay bing
bunny girl
there's pegging lore everyone seems to be aware of the characters we're almost at two million
when i'm first try an extra bonus one the multi-ball is so cool it gives you a super
wicked extra chance to get a free ball as well wait that was straight i was i don't know why i'm
sorry please forgive i'm sorry i'm not awake yet i don't i am awake but i'm not awake yet that was
that couldn't have gone anywhere so let's not do that again okay and i missed everything
and my extra ball went straight in the gutter gutter i hardly even know
thank you uh why did that okay it didn't work again stop trying to do the same thing it's clearly
not working how am i supposed to do it what clear the blue
you should try and sing the lyrics to the song of the i don't even know what the song
isn't it land or whatever do the gospel music is always like in the lingo
use the mouse cursor to help aim i think uh oh my god i can't believe that i'm being backseat
gamed oh my god i'm absolutely outraged oh my god i can't believe it backseat gamed oh
oh my god my my ego okay three balls left right it's not going well it's not going well in the
pego community i need free balls and this is in my way so i can't even oh is this that didn't go in
okay bucket we ball come aww ai you so could have easily anything eat that the game is roasting me i know
oh don't be afraid to spread out a little right you kiss off oh i missed it stop doing that that's
the third time you've done that and you know it doesn't work and you keep trying to do it look i'm
special okay how about that one let's do this side instead there we go there we go that looks better
i like it we got free balls orange attack i don't really feel like i'm but sure
how do i hit this no i clearly don't get permission to hit that one
okay you done we don't ever have to do that one okay what are we got we've got five
i think we're safe i think we've got it
three
two i love how you tell yourself off it's just because i'm like brah
yeah and everything gets randomized so there isn't like a set way to
i'm sorry
they will spread your crony hips here you oh my god it's snail the fewer orange pegs left
there are more points you get check the red fever meter on the right hand side of the board
for the current point multiplier all right uh
then
wait that wasn't even orange that wasn't even orange i'm getting hypnotized by this game i have to
um i'm getting rather in fact to me it's like to the point where i'm like
like i don't want to i don't want to commentate because i'm like this is so sad playing
night i think i'm gonna have to hit that one in order to get sure i'll take the two balls
can i put my balls on your jaw
is there multiplayer in this game stop is there at the server see don't think i won't
pull out peggle multiplayer i'll fucking do it i'll actually roll and smoke all of you in multiplayer
peggle it's over for your both for your ip address and your your street credit because you're gonna
get annihilated by me in this game local only dinky let's do that
oh uh fortunately i don't think we have this oh well after that maneuver definitely not
okay well i tried okay let's go again go again go again you can have my ip if you want just let
me know i need to know
no i was gonna try and go for the green
oh that's fine i feel so seishi it was such a maneuver oh oh i have to the audio cues as well
they're really feeding into the gamble addiction right now is this the new balochro lucky bounce
oh it'll take splashing up there is a guy who made his twitch chat play peggle peggle too has
online multiplayer but it's an absolute nightmare oh no i'm easily addicted allegedly like have you
ever done recreational jokes before me who is like cripplingly addicted to like already unhealthy
things like lack of sleep lack of um what much i say sorry the game's literally hypnotizing me
oh my god i can't talk okay we've got free ball fucking ball there's loads of stuff in my way
um i'm here for the game's lame gather all the vices literally
ah have you ever done recreational jokes no motherfucker i would get addicted
should we be concerned no you should be happy that i'm aware enough about my wait no i'm not
if i don't fuck up the shop
is it gonna hit that corner
oh okay okay i shouldn't move the cursor though
okay oh i need to sync it up if i'm just sending it okay we did it saved saved call
call call call call call call call call call call call call call call call call call call call
oh we won okay i will time hold down the right mouse button to speed up time this will help if
you're waiting oh my god i see and snow berries how did don't starve together go was it as confusing
as it looked
yeah like confusing as anything the game it was so fun oh you enjoyed it it was hard oh hi
embers as well it would it looked very difficult oh the only thing i know about the lore of that
game hype and foul um is that uh
that um willow is apparently the easiest hype and felt high snow berries
uh we're playing bagel uh and i just realized the screen is horribly out of sync
you can't see the top of the screen what the heck is going on sorry this game is so old that i had
to like capture it awkwardly and nope that's my layout hold on a minute you're gonna have to do
i don't know why all of a sudden it's like zoomed out i didn't realize
you see and hello what hello lollipops not the other term where the heck is this game
i can't find it nope that's me hold on nope what i can't even find where i'm capturing the game
right now hold on i know it's terrible scuff i promise okay why is it so cut off
puzzle capture nope that's me stop stop puzzle capture uh-huh
it sees the whole thing but it won't let me unlock right why is it cut off at the top
hold i've literally just what have i been streaming like that the whole time with the
thing cut off at the top is i've been cut off the whole time
bruh no why did i not see anything scuff straight right none of you saw that i didn't even notice
to be honest bruh okay look you can see what stage we're on up here stage two and five i think
literally notice that scuff streamer but i'm so glad i mean i enjoyed the game um
the only thing i know about don't starve is that willow is like op or something because she doesn't
get sanity in the darkness i believe and our fire restores her sanity and forest fires and stuff
or something like that i can't even remember uh last ball well we're not gonna get it so
just scuffle her how dare you your allegations and accusations
let's try yeah but this time actually try okay wait can i
that's unfortunate the green was there because it just gets shut down straight down
don't worry about it just focus on the pegging real and true but i'm so glad i mean i enjoyed
the little collab together i'm sure it was adorable i uh have a very cute thumbnail next week
that features me and one of the girls hmm i think you guys will find it quite cute
god i'm robert i'm i'm like i'm sure there's something i'm missing
logic wise scuff sucky all right i'll allow that not to be confused with our cousin business
be sucky the hit beach of our agency right can i grab this one yeah oh well it literally did nothing
okay now hold on how do i do this
i don't
is there even a clear shot
is there i don't think there's a clear is there a clear shot that okay fuck off
all right i messed up but it's fine there isn't a clear shot right let's try that again
why stop putting the green one there that's such rubbish like spawn because it's just gonna fall
straight down the side i can't believe those were the words that introduced me your agency
would she be like oh welcome to be sucky right the rails
brah who knew pegging could be so hard literally why is it so difficult
point boosts i'm not here for your points i'm here for the win i want to unlock that it will
apparently it's op give me the owl you are mine you are mine
so i'm having a rubbish luck on this one oh i missed also me who's doing like just terrible
am i really that bad am i supposed to be strategizing or something
because i'm starting i'm starting to feel personally attacked by this game why is it
given me such a random like terrible randomized luck i'm a feel personal attack this is not a
brainless game don't say such the horrible things to me what do you mean i have to use my brain
what do you mean i have to think that's outrageous these accusations these allegations they're unfounded
and i will be uh uh uh uh uh uh sucking at the game but not to be confused with the sucking at
the game which is a different thing it's meant for a patient i don't know my pago teachers life
lessons like patients i think but it does you have to think it's over literally any IQ game and i'm
done so absolutely done so munk munk
how many i've got three balls
like i suck i suck
this game gets a lot harder if you don't use your brain right thank goodness it's a two hour
stream then thank goodness over honestly i think the number of pegs we're assuming you're catching
many at the bottom of the three bar see that green one is always there which is useless
it doesn't do anything for me i assume the ai is going to get nicer the more you lose in a roll
sure that's just straight copium but like why wouldn't the ai get nicer the more it realizes
i'm losing like come on come on
just get in the hole just get in the hole seriously cat we are actually we are doing tactical
pegging in real time we're getting a redonkulous i'm not even got into the eyes yet right let's get
more as if that didn't ping off the one that was strategically aiming for
okay let's get inside this okay there we go that's what i want inside
i'm ready getting that whole okay so we need to get rid of that one because it's the only one on
that side really i think we should just send it for this green one and then okay okay no maybe i have
oh it's not going to work
uh oh i think we did it no no no
how am i supposed to trick shot this
it's getting out to me how am i supposed to trick shot that how have i got this
blue on the left and bound cut
mods time out that wifling
time out that wifling that any wifling that says aim for that left one
get i'm out of here for 10 seconds get i'm out of here don't ever be spitting that again
and my general direction yeah absolute spanking for that one it should have been there
to be fair i was probably gonna lose anywhere i was gonna lose anyway it's fine it's fine
um ye don't worry if you never saw but i i've been having tummy pain
um i think due to stress no don't don't don't only come um but the reason why i'm bringing it up
is because i literally have no tummy ache right now so if that doesn't tell you the state of um
the the the environment on how happy i am to be with you to stream and stuff
just thought you should know that i really appreciate your time together unironically
i know no don't be sick how are you being sick i'm just telling the what's going on don't be sick
you're paying um but yeah i i have i had a very sore stomach yesterday i had it this morning
and i literally just noticed right now i don't have it and i'm like hmm there's definitely a
correlation on why i don't have a sore tum tum right now i wonder what it oh we did it
okay the ai said you know what you're on your fourth round let's hurry up a bit let's speed things
up a bit thank you pego love you johnny love you love you please let's go
oh wait we unlocked the new character wait so can we unlock the field thing
the faces of the pyramid master cat's top meow i like yarn but not as much as i like my pyramid
it extends the edges of the free ball bucket for extra bounces and last second reprieve
it's subtle but it can really help you out graze with me into the pyramid and all
oh gaze not graze sorry if it's on my mind clearly graze with me
oh my god my magic ball turns the free ball bucket in our pyramid
what does that mean
huh oh to like bounce it back up okay okay i see it i respect it
i've hit like and retweet because the pegging community is dying uh can i even hit that one
mummy just this is a lot she doesn't seem to find her body it's withdrawal symptoms i mean
i mean you're not wrong because i i i'm definitely getting some relief
as i said my stomach doesn't hurt but like hurting last night and i didn't know if i should
take painkillers or not but i was convincing myself i'm like oh my god oh my god i'm turning
into peter jackson i've got a stomach ulcer oh like i was looking up symptoms and stuff i thought
um
radical free ball i think we did it on the first one
lack of sleep cousins though i've never had the cane just tell me eat before it's way different
than anything i've had before we game in my pyramid power last five turns
that's a lot of turns
oh oh tell him how it is pagle tell him how it is tell him how it is let them know pagle let them
know oh no i wanted that orange one sorry but i got
okay well i need to get rid of that blue one anyway it's literally in the way so
yeah maybe it just the the after effects in the stress relief
probably as i said i'll give me give me one week and you know i'll probably just
i love putting a free ball in my damn street you're giving me more help
as if it never touched it as if it never touched it i feel personally attacked by that okay
you get tough oh cheeky we hang honestly you right done
i quite like the egyptian power i think the ability to like bounce back a lot and
locked in the free ball
thank you again for all the membership cheers today we did unlock a new emote slot i will be
contacting the more artists and for the girls and and start getting all the the little png hearts
are all going to start disappearing because i'll actually have the emotes for the girls
um i as always i'll be last i'll i'll get all their stuff done first um i
important that we didn't is there is not come up after years yes but there's has edit mine
didn't have any edit that just meant did i even aim for anything i'm not sure
your beloved yeah the pregnancy emote the
bro i need to start focusing i'm such a fake pegle fan clearly i'm doing this for
me
can we get the you want a pregnant emote
how
how how you want how you want to pregnant i don't
know we already picked the emotes um i'm going to get in a more of us kissing
um if i if it's gonna work oh my god how many do i have left
well that blue is right in my way so i don't even have a choice in that
doesn't matter don't need the choice don't need your advice take the l and
the good thing we have an extra slot now get can we get happy at roofling absolutely
i once thought nothing could be playing with a ball of yarn but pegle tops that i'm keeping
the yarn though yarn heads what is that random is this a child's game or is this just like a nice
casual cute game is this for children be honest am i losing that child's game right now i've already
lost once this week to a child's game or what i thought was a child's game i don't even know i'm
gonna have to look up who the the customers were because it wasn't me it's more cat it's a baby
game not even child it's a newborn baby game you know what your accusations are on
it wasn't out you rude thing you
you okay i need to wait for it to go away don't do that again
how am i supposed to time the other ones like all the way over here i'm just gonna
oh the blue one was in the way haha i had tunnel vision it's a boomer casual phone game like candy
oh my god i'm i've never been more insulted in my life sorry but it's a good game it's a
good game i'm i'm addicted and i can't quit
bonk i've got am i gonna make it oh my god we might make it hold on we might make it
oh i didn't have to do anything great this is stage three i don't know if we're going to be able
to unlock all the characters in time but i ain't gonna stop me i'm addicted to not the child i'm
addicted oh i've got a fever and the only cure is extreme fever haha get it get it not really
it's ironic because the cure for my fever is actually more fever
okay this one actually looks uh this one's got a little a little space to it
they're 55 levels okay this might need a part two
not gonna lie i actually didn't expect and not that i didn't i think i was gonna hate it i didn't
expect to actually enjoy the casual nature i think because like obviously yesterday's stream was
very long um it's kind of nice just to tune out and watch ball go and do things you know
it's a good just hand game absolutely agreed wholeheartedly
okay
i spell a game and you can just you Japanese in the background
whoo although this one
got a little i don't really that confident unless it keeps giving me free balls i'm literally not
gonna argue i'm not gonna argue i'm not
yeah i think the pyramid is like a pretty good bonus as i said it's like hitting stuff that
might be in our way even though the ball should like you know perish on the
the wheel thing we need a yap game tierless honestly so does that mean strong as big enough
i mean in this stream yeah such a good game
okay i think we're gonna do it not to jinx ourselves not to jinx from the hit video game
legal legends which turned into the hit show arcane which apparently the next season's coming out
sometime soon well yeah we're gonna be on the next character in no time
i'm even clear all the pay
yep ambition content
the splendor of the sleepless master sploir splork splorkin greetings
inspired peg or not just anyone in the chat identify as a peg or not are any of my reeflings
adventures of the pegging peggling sorry my task is to expound expound on expelodious
space blast for furious vulgaration and fabulous firework many pegs will be sparkly
dismissed and pointful a cure at the speed of shock set ocular eyes to see and we shall
launch our lesson what are you even talking about blorp he's looking at me with his one
gleby eye blorp powers are magical hit green peg for space blast cosmic explodation
oh that's actually a really cool one
that's really cool i like that one alien alien pretty good
late but hello hi reeflings don't worry we are just peggling away uh i'm peggling very hard
you know we're just trying to get the outcome make sure we get the outcome that we want from this
peg peggling says like i can't even make it anymore anymore obvious at this point okay we
we're just meming up okay i can't make it anymore obvious
there's an orange one over there
oh the game really said you suck here's a free ball thank you argue i shall not thank you for
your unfortunately these blue ones are in her way so i'm gonna have to just knock them out
this is indeed a baby how do you my or she is avril avine she was a girl he was a boy can i make it
anywhere i'm here
i'm getting edged
okay thank you right after the 7.88 perfect thing i you gotta be very careful today
i will write that script i think the park bench one uh i don't know what to do with that
but mentally it's too hard for me to write right now to love that face blast gotta blast
i'm jimmy neutron okay i can't even reach the one over there okay it has to do with the
thing
that's what i said sodium chloride jimmy what you even on a
what is that sodium chloride it's just salt it's a thick do you think you're superior
the crowdsourced it i knew such an innocent game could have a pegging and edging real
uh this one is
you didn't see that that was embarrassing okay that was genuinely embarrassing
genuinely didn't expect to just
okay uh i'm gonna see
i'm gonna go for no i'm not i'm gonna go for this one because it's
and that one will get picked up on the way down because of the way there
oh i did it i did it
we i saw good at this the game looks so old the game is so old um i am the what you see on
stream is actually bigger than what i'm playing on that makes sense the screen is so small i
couldn't get it to work in full screen at all it just was not happening and we also surpassed
5000 total score uh great something sometimes blue pegs block a good shot to orange hit the blue
we still in tutorial mode after all this time that was the worst way you could have fallen
and you know exactly what you did video i was clearly supposed to go on the green one
right see you gotta blast
oh wait maybe it i don't know if i should have kept that i actually
gotta blast oh my god point first when i get literally no pegs oh my god thank you for the point
oh a long shot bonk
how much did this franchise make if they made a peg or two i can definitely see the easy addictive
nature i played somewhere still on the xbox that's literally how i know about this game
i thought it was on game pass but only two is on game pass so
it maybe we'll finish so i've got a sonic hero stream coming up maybe we'll continue to play this after
sugar i don't think i can hit that either of them
oh
what i was gonna do is hit it off of that so it like bounces onto that do you know what i mean
oh right that was far one that was far too much
i can't yeah i can't do it oh that's so annoying
let's play oh let's try that game
mummies really enjoying the peg i think this is a good game like i don't remember playing it i just
remember like mucking about but like this is enjoyable this is like perfect that's the material
as well like especially for streamers that like are really sure are too deep into games i mean
f**k just put this up this is like so easy i am currently brainless i think to me and just
yapping it in i think this is a fantastic game for streamers and i heavily recommend it for
oh we got a free ball okay what am i looking at can i destroy look at that green one oh i definitely
have very bad tunnel vision in these kind of games please work with me game oh my gosh
does that have enough if the game doesn't hate me i might have enough oh no the game hates me it's okay
come on
i think we have it
okay thank you for saving me ai because that was embarrassing
oh okay we did it this alien is going to be over and done with real quick we didn't even use the
bonus on him i feel like it's a guilty pleasure by hardcore gamers is why chat knows all the lore
exactly pegels are just thunder game damn straight gloar purple pegs change place after every show
points are plenty if you catch the purple pig
i'm already i can't believe i'm saying it but literally i'm already reading it 10 out of 10
it's so good okay let's get right into the oh i was gonna put it in the ball but i guess not
i will definitely take the free ball stop going to the right side where there's a
how am i doing that i don't know
literally i don't see any creditables where violet gets her ultra reshield out and dash is like
how are you doing that and she's like i don't know literally that's what's happening to me right
now i'm like uh how are we winning i'm putting zero strategy into this oh god that's right in the
way of that one okay oh okay that's what i mean with tunnel vision
i did a trick shot i'm so smart okay can i do it with these two
oh i think i won again
okay we're gonna be done with the alien real quick real real quick
absolute mlg hours 360 no scope get me on the speedrun record get me on the accolades
get me on games done quick charity event because i'll be right there on peg all
just amazing everyone like ah you're welcome the lorp a glit clear more orange pegs early
or focus on single tricky glass sure you don't have to tell me twice
oh this one looks actually a wee bit difficult
but i did get the left side
i was hoping it was gonna bounce on that orange okay i did it did hit the orange one there
let's get up wait no why did i go for the bonus point there's no point then go for the bonus point
strongly beating the pain what about you the speedruns like five seconds or something
they'll be like skipping the the
because they're just so good at the game
mmm this one's a tricky map all right especially if the ai's just like beating me up stop pinging
to the left stop pinging to the left do you understand me get in the middle right now
no get the orange ones you're missing everything on purpose video game i know exactly what shenanigans
you're up to this last ball right well nothing's happening so the adventure mode speedrun is
four to eight minutes i yapped longer than the speedrun of this game
how can someone play 45 eight 48 minutes what i don't get it
well we're okay we maybe maybe maybe aren't making the the history of this as if i missed it
okay okay this is actually pretty rough not gonna lie
hmm i'm penalizing i'm penalizing
i'm strategizing i'm strategizing i'm pinging i'm pinging gotta blast
okay can i hit that one get everything out my way thank you because it's literally all in the
way of each other and i only have five left
clearly she needs more experience with pegging i for one volunteer's tribute thank you refling
exactly that's what i want to see so we actually technically
oh but everything's in the way of that one
there's nothing we can do it's all yeah
i can't um unless i send it
oh
oh my god i didn't tame that at all to get a free ball that was so lucky
oh my god that was so lucky
oh my god stage five flip for keep it going cloud lobster
that means i am clouding your english have you tried the flippies as they are when you
fail with them you will learn to flip the bells back against the world for extra points like a
station ball no need to be shy my name let me let us dive right in yes all right
it's all french
a jet my magic power is flippies after hitting the green pig click anywhere to slip them
that is a really good click to flip
oh my god that's kind of OP wait so the ball just never drops
i can literally dictate the ball never drops
no AI don't work against me work with me
nah no chance get back up there get back up there yep get back up there i'm not having it
get up there i'm not having it you're no dropping good
that's right get back up there get to work put in that work
get up there spank that ball spank that ball just the one
no up get up
okay we are back on this side oh male the okay we got another no stop pinging it halfway across
the map it's literally refusing to roll no ah sorry i'm i'm stubborn i'm stubborn i refuse to
let this drop when i know for a fact that AI can point it up and it's refusing to hit any other ball
i am clearing this motherfucking thing
no i refuse i'm too good at this okay look i played bingo highway
i don't have this one stop it
did you see that the AI jammed me okay that's more like it now get up that mm-hmm mm-hmm
that's what i thought mm-hmm okay maybe i'll let it go just this once i don't know if i'm still getting
get up up up okay
okay yeah uh-huh uh-huh mm-hmm that is right you mothers fuckers this
lifestyle is winning this game i am literally uh how they say a rolling and smoking this game
and i would flip flop yes no okay yeah oh oh yeah mm that is my biggest score yeah
uh we still have click to flip on i don't know how long it lasts but i'll take it
okay no one because apparently it just went off the map uh it's okay i didn't want any extra points
anyway i like trick shot between my my people oh right you
do okay we did it
cleared half of the level in a shot literally feels good man
okay we can just send them right down the middle
it's absolutely awful i'm not even speaking proper sentences i don't even know how to speak proper sentences
and it totally wasn't because i had absolute uh determination to not let that first one go
if you're gonna keep oh my god wait my peril's on the screen don't look my peril is on the screen
six million
why are you wasting my time like this no uh the fish is now in my way in the other side so
so
we have introduced obstacles and obstacles in my pago board more likely than you think sorry
i forgot i had flip first that oh i thought maybe we could have got cheeky cheeky free ball
i can't believe it new mechanics the power creep is real just because power creep is happening
and all these multiplayer games please don't think it isn't happening in peggle as well
do not be ignorant to the the trials and tribulations that the gaming industry faces
okay this i definitely don't think we're winning this one i think uh
oh i needed to be a bit more strategic but hey oh the there's too much stuff in the way there's too
much stuff on the board
oh my gosh i want oh
don't write me out yet don't hurt him now okay maybe write me out a little bit
yeah last ball let's just go for that one there's no way i was doing it
peggle session pass win peggle premium premium pass you want to start any harder i don't know do you
i'll make it worse please i'm already struggling with my words and i have to do a freaking ASMR
stream i have to articulate i'm definitely gonna a grab a sugary snack
you come on sebastian as this is uh how you say shit gameplay whoa sebastian never really asked
for that kind of feedback maybe make it a bit easier what are you talking about uh is the AI
is already helping you as much as possible oh you are just how they say milled right sebastian
that's enough right you didn't even keep hammering home about it i get it can't wait for the starter
smart you guys were so nice when i started in the booty clap video or whatever video i can't
remember there was one audio that i like started really badly and i just left it and everyone was
like oh that's cute and i'm like yeah that's what i got that's what i got when i'm offline thank you
cool pun to ka punta ka punta is how i would say it as a score we're becoming a member
and the direct support please enjoy the emotes that includes the pregnancy one but it will be
replaced maybe no i don't know the i don't know if you guys are actually wanting a pregnancy
don't think i won't do it you get the fuck out of the way you're just doing it to upset me
try to upset me clearly and now all the blue ones are in the way
hey how do i keep getting free balls what's going on
oh right okay i jinxed it i'm sorry
can i hit that one without hitting the blue one
next stage
you just need to ask i think they want to try locked in for the free balls to get
let's look up and see the free balls what oh maybe these are waves are tricky take your time
and you're just fine
anyway i am off to eat my pain du chocolat or chocolatine because for some reason in france
they're having a big old fight about the difference between pain du chocolatine and a chocolatine
so there's some french drama if you wanted to know it um yeah don't don't ask i don't know why
i do not know france loves real and true
i miss what we got
hey
french argue about everything how many casualties so far in the conflict it's not looking good
some businesses are taking a it's controversial if you run a bakery and it says chocolatine
and a certain like right you're in my way forget to fuck right you're in my way forget to fuck
okay we did it how long until france writes the tweet longer did you know there's a france
follow for more horrifying fags oh no oh no did you leave
hey you can keep your flip-flops into a flip-flop position by holding down the button i actually
didn't know that so merci beaucoup i did i did not know that uh no uh ne pas je ne pas dsol
but merci pour la information information i know it's hard to believe but i was taught french
by a scottish teacher and basically she had a very harsh accent so to say what's the date is
say uh quel est le date aujourd'hui but because i was taught about um taught by a scottish teacher
basically my brain goes
i'm sorry that happened to you yeah basically um so whenever um it's kind of beautiful whenever
i speak french i'm constantly fighting the um
i like as the accent and that's why like when i do the french i do the much lighter much nicer
voice uh because like yeah it's like
you know
don't face it embrace it
i like
can i get um oh i just put it in the bin i have two balls left good thing i only have one thing to
hit strong your friend oh my god i'm so sorry i'm so sorry literally it was it was
fucking a scottish you can't make it up it was a scottish teacher teaching french and it's like
okay what's the weather k tom fae tale what's the weather and then all of us were like oh
it'll play illy i do so lie uh it'll now neage like for snow and stuff i'm so sorry that's how
i've been called it that's how it is that's why like i like absolutely look out oh yeah
uh it's just terrible i do apologize if there are any french speakers pegle me even if i say no
i don't know oh i don't know i'm sure we can get away with that one chief
thank you fucking dynasty that's hilarious um
how should i encourage such things
right book only got six but this triangle oh that was really mean the game game you could give me that
the game you're exactly what i was trying to hit okay
come on keep it going keep it going eggs bacon grits sausage
i only have four left but there's so much blue in the way
well right i need to like you know what
okay okay okay let them get up let them get up how do i hit you i think i can just do it
directly let them get up i'm peggling so hard right now i can't peggle any harder
hydration check reeflings i've not hydrated since that cup of tea
it's like trying to open my bottle of water burning my fingers trying to open the thing because of
the oh speaking of me master rinfield pumpkin what hello there my name is rinfield behind me is my
valet i gore together we will demonstrate the space bending qualities of the spooky ball don't
be alarmed use with care the spooky ball can earn points like you've never imagined let's try it
what what do you do my magical powers spooky ball when you hit the green peg the ball will
spookily go around the screen twice i'm so scared okay
i'm scared reeflings i don't know what it is
does that work sorry i had water in my mouth
does that make it go twice nuclear do that moment scared
you're scared in french you say
um
when i don't think i can get any more negative emotes obvious i feel so bad that like the only
way you can express yourself like via emotes is um strong a hug or uh basically are your only
two emotions that you can express to me peggle turned into a horror game oh oh okay oh oh oh
we got it we got itch twice that was so good that was so good we got freaking itched away
we're at seven million uh seven point eight million score amazing moment thank you my darling
i swicky goes to the bottom and repairs the top
and see when see spider plays up the water top
don't game sorry and watch the spider
oh oh this is a cool map cool hi y'all i love how you guys develop that that's so good
my little moon
i like it i'm here for it okay let's get you because i'm not gonna get you naturally but
i might be able to clear some blue out the way for the other shots by kind of doing highest
to lowest i don't know if that's the worst i don't know we hit a low so
even the balls are spooky we're making it through the campaign mode i've not been funny
mercy if you're looking for like the easiest that's the experience of your life get peggle
i just let it was like seven ad which i think canadian would be the same i don't know if ad
and canadian's like on the same on the same wavelength
yeah unfortunately there's a lot okay thanks goodness that happened i was hoping it was gonna
this game it's testing me come on you know i want you to stay on the right side of the map
but why are you flying to the left side stop it you're upsetting me video game
i hear get peggle's mercy no no no the video game the video game the video game
it's like really good that's it i'm chilling it's so fun the ai is taken over so i don't even have to
think we missed it by a ball here there was one left right let's start up top
so maybe it's better to go for the green right away
i hit both green right away
vealer peggle arc honestly who's the best peggler and vealer let's find out real quick
oh
whoa that was a big one that was a big round big round
okay i definitely need those blues to like clear up or there's we're gonna run into that problem
where i can't aim for anything without like a miracle trick shot or it's giving me a free ball
to try and like clear a little bit more of the map you know
oh
oh wait hold on hold on don't write me don't put me back in coach put me back in i think i've
got this one i think i've got this one oh put me back in put me back in don't write me off put me
back in the peggle tournament it's mummy i'm the best at peggle
um
i love that i love it
oh what oh it's a cobra in the background oh my god it's hypnosis is this about is this game about me
so
peggle is every day the snake is just like oh my god are we we're on the same wavelength
i can't believe it any any wavelengthers
me like monk i just have to do that ace mushrooms
um how am i supposed to get that one there
the one that's under here how am i supposed to get that one
it doesn't really seem like that trick showable it seems like randomized unless it's going to
bounce off the blue that one's curious have you tried a peggle in main building the yandere pool
also can uh extends outside of a gist game i don't know how am i supposed to get it classic
true brain so with skills the scottish accent is the only reason i'm staying here i'm sorry you
don't enjoy i'm sorry i'm sorry everything else about me is unenjoyable i mean the if the
pregnancy smart wasn't enough to really end i don't know what else can do it chief i'm
apologize there we're all at gas on that after the that one how am i supposed to get this one
like a wall
uh i can't do it
oh
why am i born like this okay let's try that again don't put them behind that that's so difficult
what the heck i literally threw that in this game you either peg or get pegles and i just got
pegged i just got pegged wait hold on i don't need bro i can't you know what jock i'm trying to make
you know what fuck it you know what jock i was trying to make you know what i was trying to make
don't you dare don't you dare act like you don't know what jock i was trying to make
recover with a rim shot hit it with a rim shot
right right okay that right mm-hmm i'm gonna need the ai to step up and be nice to me right now
be nice to me i have just put your pegle sales up by one okay potentially five if the other girls
want a nice that's the experience so actually you're usually you owe me right now you owe me
when in doubt rim shot real i'm just okay mm-hmm right mm-hmm no okay i'm starting to need free
balls i need balls i need free ones or else the cobra wins again
not gonna make whose trick shot was that that was terrible wasn't terrible maybe not maybe not
maybe not
was that down or off i was supposed to go
ah stop pin them in awkward areas what am i supposed to do
i'm not wise enough i'm not smart enough right i can hit that one at least
well there we go i can get you free balls mommy
oh the yarn the law the law monka is the law
did it stop hiding them under these how am i supposed to hit these if there's nothing to like
wallet somewhere mercy on the hunt on the prowl
uh right let's bonk that there
me
uh this is going
mildly catastrophic mildly catastrophic keeps the scissors away remember that time it could
have been a caramba in my stupidity remember that time i got taken off the development okay
this one is hard i am really struggling with this map now before you're like i don't know
stroney maybe if you aimed properly yes yes yes i'm aware but i want to use my brain
so instead i will accept that i'm just doing bad okay
ah
a i saved a i saved a i saved b a i saved b
oh my god right we'll get 10 million easy peasy oh look at the bat
watch out the wall of blue pegs makes this level a challenge spooky balls can help
what do you mean by me 100 perfect everything was planned why yes of course
the development didn't ridicule me at all i'm gonna have to last an hour
um
okay okay okay all right all right all right all right
six you could maybe do to get rid of all the blues in the way
weird okay okay let them get up let them get up let them get up
okay so these are in my way
we did it i'm we got an extra ball fucking we both
bang oh yeah man i'm gonna admit it i i was i'm missing wait well that's not even an English
sentence man i miss playing this is a six-year-old quite a pretty whatever it's full
uh oh don't hurt him now don't hurt him let's do it favor score
eight point eight point eight million total score okay we got Casper the spooky ball comes
out of the top of the board at the same spot as the left on the ball what does that mean
i don't know and i missed it i got one orange from them
okay okay hopefully we can clear away those blues i body i've been dying i was do
i would beat off of
um
oh i've never seen that before oh my god new mechanic a lot the boys can get like
let's let's pop him get him out of the way anonymous we thought strone's weakness was
mirrors no turns out strone's true weaknesses games that require you to think how dare you
one how dare you speak with such confidence and on to publicly say that out loud two thank you for
the tip three how dare you okay i like a no thinking experience okay it's a put put me in jail
put me in jail if it's illegal to like a me if it was uh illegal to enjoy a thoughtless experience
okay oh did we just get edged we did mommy's a gamer god real and true undeniable gamer
no thanks just peg literally let me strone in a little peg i'll let me feel a little recline
i'm glad you enjoy the game even though i have literally been hand carried through the full thing
fever score and we got an extra 10k for the leftover 9.2 million it's only it was that easy
oh my god it's the sampler for conquer's bad for day conquer honey care for a bone
what a sunny day what you say it's raining well even a rainy day can be sunny with a bright perspective
i'm tula and i'm thrilled that i get to share my flower power with you i'm so helpful the way it
lights up orange pegs every time lots of folks say it's their favorite i hope it's yours let's find
out but i love mindbroken mummy my magic power is flower power it lights up orange pegs it's so pretty
wait i at random she'll highlight green pegs uh sorry or at random
so wouldn't it be best to save the green to the very last she's like a hail mary type ultimate
thank you brulee legend for this super chat i'm a mindbroken a sunflower kind of
let me pull up the sunflower real quick quick from conquer's bad for day because i'll do it
she a baddie she knows she attend hey right about eight left trying to clear the kind of awkward
yeah oh wait what must be random the sunflower with boobers yeah and right for those of you who
haven't played conquer's bad for day it's the most bizarre experience of your life and the long
and short short of it is there's a sunflower who's once you tickle her with a bee she reveals her
fondle abyssums to you and you jump on it in order to get some money because you need money to
progress in the war um 9.5 million flower power lights up one fifth of the remaining
orange pegs that means the sooner you use it the more pegs you'll get well say no more to me
say no more you need not explain yourself to me darlin uh right you
yeah easy peasy limits i guess yeah it really is just randomize what hits though
sunflower gen 4 confront real and true happening right now the the concept's already made
just within those 10 seconds it's already made she's already been approved for progress yep
so so if we tickle you uh i promise you um rest this is they're not gonna appear out of nowhere
for me i'm afraid uh after the old emmy clip it's really solidified that i definitely have the
smallest chest of everyone in violor um so yeah the best you're gonna get is maybe a clap a round
of applause how about that if you tickle me you get a round of applause okay that was a terrible
one don't do that again what are you doing okay oh dear did i win one remaining drat that wasn't
impossible if you tickle her she'll put a round of applause that's the best you're getting from me
hopefully you're still playing this when i get home it looks interesting oh i'm so sorry today's
a short day because the stream um 13 hours yesterday it's just kind of a more casual day
watch the buzz don't forget to leave a like if you enjoy the peggle community and pegging
me me checking the stream statistics in this stream is like astronomically liked more than
like the usual amounts of likes that are left on a stream that would be funny and i will love it
right so if i bombed it it gave me one
oh we got a free ball though okay i think we have this one though it's a weak caterpillar
note 13 i'm a stream today no my voice is raw my throat is so sore right now and i'll
actually have to go do it somewhere uh huh what if i lost the ability to speak uh huh wouldn't that be
so funny and hilarious i would know it would not be and it's sheepster is coming on today
the flower power lights up the closest orange pegas it's like a happy little bouquet right there on
the board all right i'll take it aw the little bear having his wee oh that was a good one i like that
um you lose your ability to protest
okay i'm gonna have to get rid of these orange ones here or it's just not happening
oh okay we got the ball though oh there's wee froggy in the river
i need more honey to eat looks like it yeah 4 p.m for sheebie i have terrible news
i'm not in the same time zone as you or her so does that mean she's coming on in eight minutes
or is she coming on any minute the pegging community stands with veiler damn straight
oh i thought i was gonna get that in oh dear it didn't quite fit refling oh no we're just gonna
have a second to go out of while they bounce us out right let's
i don't think there's a point of actually hitting the green one you know that
in eight minutes okay six am osu! time uh amen thank you right who are we missing we used to
we completely missed that's okay i didn't want to i didn't want to win anyway
we didn't use more loot now hold on a minute
oh my god the hundred bonus we made it 10 million we made the 10 million score
oh yeah
i think it's really important to be environmentally aware that's why i only drive a car made of
imaginary magical breath all right whatever makes you happy
that's very cute i like how they tried to give the characters like a wee bit oh that was bounce
it's the road oh that's so creative it's like the roads
it says sheebie doesn't stream for another 30 hours am i being pranked am i being pranked
sheebie might be doing a rain check uh
since trinket might not be up to their club i'll come here
virgin fox thank you for the membership please enjoy the most sorry about the pregnancy one
kind of not sorry at the same time you know you know what you signed up for come on you know
at this point you take a little glance at my youtube channel you know what you signed up for
come on that's right that's right i'm i'm victim blaming i'm victim blaming and what you're gonna
do about it nothing did you know i'm right i do love coming out with absolutely ridiculous
stuff right let's get right can i get this side oh i was a bit too early i was meant to premature
that's okay okay there we go good and then we just need the road one that's here
the best one uh it's the link
strutting whispers curse takes new year when
uh i think they're right and then
i'm gonna discard the arm jump on this one hold on sorry it says pause this is
start to ask are you shooting in a moment
here we go oh my god leaks just for this
if you um if you have any tips or advice for you what oh i don't have any tips or advice for
you this time i just hope you're having fun what the fuck that's so nice and awesome i am having
fun thank you so much for asking a little sunflower
okay sheepsters is able to stream right so we will redirect so for any living hair
on members i assure you you'll be redirected into your boot in just a second it started when we
were young you were my
wow this one's difficult actually
um i'm analyzing the map and we're having to hit angles basically
i have a sore throat precision sunflower's voice like i'm willing to put myself in pain for you
i would catch a grenade maybe not uh as much as i like to think i'm indestructible
i have to admit explosives c4 serenade for example
no don't think i'm not that indestructible you know when i'm in the old the pregnancy
ASMR had more sense of meaning than some modern film and games oh i'm getting crit... i'm here for
i'm here to get crit for it though i guess that somebody uh got surprised by the comments so many
were like oh my god what's the sequel or wait oh my god can i do it
viable hair amen viable hair i'm sorry but we're booting up this game again i don't care what
anyone says i don't i don't care what anyone says this is amazing oh we got the rabbit oh my god
we got the rabbit it's just in time for shi shi hold on let me make sure i'm redirecting successfully
we are going to play the rabbit though and then i'll redirect into her okay let me let me play
let me play it's your for for for for for for for for any very brief links or member i'm going to
do a hand-cam ASMR but i do need a moment to set it up because i need to clean my desk and i'm not
even kidding um that's literally the region that's going to be delayed uh
okay uh one second smash or pass smash or passing
are you squiddin me right now okay cool i mean it looks like this right it looks like the smash
or pass yeah i see it right okay i'll make sure she's definitely live before we redirect because
i don't want to know it's you what you stand anonymous thank you for this ten you're not
saying anything though i i'll take as your support for the pegging community thank you
ten dollars equals 10 i'm sure i could make a joke but i can't okay warren rabbit step right up
do you feel lucky oh wait he's a squeaker step right up do you feel soft and cream okay really
lucky how about super lucky that you came at the right place luck spin is the magic power for folks
who like to take a chance free balls triple shots magic has all these are more can be yours
let's spin anything can happen when you take a lucky spin so he does everyone's ultimate
what's the magic hat
oh my god it looks like golf it with friends or that other golf game we can put like accessories
ten dollars equals ten inches of support damn right hello there hi we're playing figgles we're
pegging so hard don't worry we're just learning what the rabbit does i'm not someone said the rabbit
okay but it's the magic hat oh god oh god i'm not ready are real oh wait a minute i forgot the
the cross station what is the difference between a lobster with a boob job and a dirty bus stop
one is a busty cross station and one is a crusty bus station
okay well
okay it's a good joke it's a good joke i don't care i don't care it's a good joke
it's is that real what the that was beautiful thank you it's one of my favorites
what's better than receiving roses on a piano
oh
two tulips on your organ
i get it as in two lips on your organ
okay sorry the booty lord 96 thank you for the 10 gifted membership and congrats to those who
caught it with their face please enjoy thank you everyone for the gifted memberships i could
you know it's literally given me so many moments um as i said we literally unlock like a new one um
get off the stage shawnee it's meant to be two lips on your organ not two tulips two tulips
oh two lips on your organ i'm so sorry i think it works with the legs then guys laugh we have to
boost their confidence artificial inflation of ego uh dry oscari dry oscari thank you so much for
coming to member in the direct support um yeah literally we unlocked them uh an emote yesterday
and i'm like there's probably gonna be another emote coming on soon keep gifts and memberships
so you can get other emotes so we can keep the prego emote oh it's on uh if you guys want the
prego emote i mean she thought it works already been made so it doesn't cost me anything thank you
again the booty lord 96 for the gifted membership and again congrats to those who caught it with your
face what do you mean you don't like these mlg skills that you're witnessing right now
not like a little doll uh i'm definitely not doing this strong in this one i'm under no illusion
bad puns magic hat makes the ball bigger i mean i know how to swell your balls as well if you give
me a chance thank you thank you oh my god i did it off the top of my head thank you
uh green garciano thank you for becoming a member bro i need to go check if i've
unironically unlocked just like a new emote slot already thank you very much green garciano
i'm sorry for bitchering everyone's name okay you need call yourself car 123 or it's over it's
actually over it's on the last one yeah let's go let's go let's go he says you haven't already
so you're giving me a seabull
aw bunk let's go again go again i'm not gonna lie i'm gonna tell you the truth right now i'm
gonna tell you the truth the fact of the matter is that other v-trippers will not tell you
i'm gonna be playing this game again i'm saying i'm i'm saying i'm gonna it's gonna be another
installment of this i'm sorry there's another installment of this game coming i will not
rest until i've completed the campaign board i don't care i love it it's fantastic it's 10 out of 10
it's a fantastic game i don't care what anyone says no
yeah it's a absolutely amazing game a 10 out of 10 experience the perfect that's it i get to get
the rush of dopamine especially when the ai like lets me win win we all know full well i
should not be winning certain shots and the ai is like ah throw you a bone oh my god please
throw me a bone throw me a bone please it's so satisfying
oh boy howdy two peggle streams can't go for real no wait oh no no more pegging
oh you can't take any more oh come on you wanted a streamer that had stamina then one
when a streamer with stamina shows up all of a sudden you're too scared to enjoy the pegle in
all right that's the bend over can i refund on membership how dare you don't act like you
don't want more pegging campaign modes what do you mean you're not in thoroughly enjoying this
gameplay use a new ball please an extra ball thank you i literally just needed that and an extra
extra ball okay let's get rid of this guy because he's oh no there's more than i there unfortunately
we're gonna run out of balls unless unless unless unless the ai okay we tried who said that
who said that mersey on the hunt relaunch right okay let's try that again
okay okay i'm addicted and i can't quit
but
uh hold on she has to open your wait room i'm gonna redirect into the wrong place
oh she's up you know what else is up my bony thank you very much
okay let's go i'm gonna try i'll finish this level but please don't think we're not playing that
playing this again okay i'm gonna redirect into shivy once we've won i promise i'm not addicted
i can quit anytime give me the magic hat right now okay multi-ball i too can handle two balls at
one time why are you so sorry okay we've got six shots left we're gonna need a min max we're gonna
need a min max
shit um right what do you do you need to okay okay hit it uh-huh let them know let them know
let them know it's not over until it's over let them know
okay it's over now because i fucked that up very badly but
sugar it's here mummy in japan it's bunny day august oh that's precious
shivy streaming on bunny day do da do da shivy streaming on bunny day all the
i don't know how to do this it's in the way there's nothing i can do unless it's gonna give me a free ball
okay i may have thrown a little bit let's try that game let's try that game
them i may have thrown a little bit but don't worry about it that was my choice it wasn't
i thought it was gonna go in i don't know why bunny
that's it time to learn japanese with scottish accent
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
200000 like that bunny day is another blessing happy fun bunny almost was a an elite gamer there
you didn't see that no actually it was a tactical ball i needed to clear the blues i was tactical
real I was 100% tactical it was not but I can tell myself
like that I need the orange one over it was a long shot oh we need to play
super monkey ball deluxe how have I not put that on the roster oh my god we
need to play super monkey ball deluxe so badly why oh my gosh right don't be
surprised if I pop up on that game soon TM okay I completely forgot about it
let's go
geez this rabbit mission is hard okay we'll do one more try if not we'll
successfully take off unless the game wants to give me yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah womp womp okay we're gonna hit the side ones because they always seem to go
in the middle anyway so there's no point in clearing in the middle some balls
they're about sending a message real it's true clear all these blue ones out
the way that game my childhood in the game that game came I thought it was an
Xbox game I don't seem to oh I'm it was a tactical it was so tactically I'll
stop it just right there okay the magic hat oh yeah oh yeah okay well oh the
magic house stays he really said pip pip cheerio I'm gonna hit that
bonk hit a bar higher an English girl oh my god imagine the game was a game
cube game pre-dated Xbox and GameCube are both the same era though oh okay we're
gonna say I don't think my dad goes I mean and it comes out no no if it stayed
in and like wiggle don't okay and one remaining no right one more try sorry
one more try one second she beat one second positons I almost had it she be a
promise positons 10 tries later okay for real the last one guys honestly I'm
redirected at a she be a promise I'm doing it right now literally it's already
there I'm doing it I'm doing it back and it's tactical it's tactical see look
we're gonna hit I was gonna say we're gonna hit an orange on the way down we
did not but that's please oh right I'm just throwing now at this point let's
let's not be around the bush that's just called throwing that's literally just
right no right I'm redirected and she be someone said can you even get mad at
this game I'm flipping region I'm out of region that just why is the AI not
helping me anymore you're supposed to be on my team
me extra ball at least there's a magical hat for fighting me when he's already
off the map you're halfway across the map right and no I'm really clean no get
it up yeah no I'm redirected in a minute right this one I'll actually redirect
into her for real for real for real like we're already start off with an extra
look at that perfect sweep come on come on look she's just warming up she's still
on our loading screen copy I'm she's not she's still on the loading screen it's
fine it's fine it's fine I will get off because I need to do a membership ASMR
stream and I need to set up for it just when I do go off give me like five
minutes for the member refling as I said I need to set up the webcam and clean my
to show you the most ridiculous thing I've ever purchased in the name of
content oh my god I'm gonna have to put clothes on check I never saw that far
ahead bad guy Martin thank you for coming a member I hope you enjoyed the
remote get wrecked by the pregnancy one in particular okay so there's an orange
one down here let's get rid of that okay I'm glad we got an extra ball from
that cuz we didn't get any benefit from that shot of my dumb assery okay okay
I would give you do it oh my god this is why you should never stop gambling it
pays off it pays off oh that was in the way it's okay we still have one day oh
we're getting aged it's okay
I work that's why you need to keep gambling 99% of jackpot winners give up
before the jackpot okay thank you so so much for this goofy game with me this was
so fun I am 100% coming back to finish it I would love to do 100% of the campaign
you and I'm going to be direct into sugar she'd be should be sugar
thank you mercy for witnessing this glorious victory as well and I would be
dire came she is streaming with her friend at shrink it please do
respectfully and you know as always when someone else is a part of your Isn't
saying if you only I'm allowed to be while
inappropriate at all times but you need to behave. Thank you so so much I'm sorry
for a very short thing please for the members who are waiting for the ASMR
membership please give me a cheeky five minutes I'm gonna get some food and I'm
gonna set up this webcam and put some clothes on thank you so you should
celebrate by tweet okay well I'm gonna pretend I don't really need that thank
you so so much and I'll see you good for givers tomorrow if not see in the
membership stream I give you one smooch, two smooch, three smooch because we're on
stage eight we got eight three eight characters so you get eight kisses one
two three four five six seven eight so many kisses I see you tomorrow I'll see
in ten minutes up yeah yeah bye bye and tomorrow's stream is whenever
delete because it's a collab bye enjoy CB and Trinket bye bye